right so um let's get started um so it's
our pleasure to have uh professor anna
gilbert who's at yale
um and she'll be telling us a little bit
about metric representations
please take it away
[Music]
okay
i think we tested everything
so i think we should be good can you
guys hear me
yay okay great
um so first of all thank you for the
invitation and uh
uh we're in this weird period of this
pandemic where uh at least i personally
am not sure do i want to travel for work
am i even allowed to travel
for work will my university reimburse me
et cetera so um i appreciate in this um
in this period um being able to do uh a
hybrid talk um
but uh i wish i wish i could be there in
person um the good news is that rishi
santalia is
is at uh simon's institute um and i
think i can see him in the
yes okay hi rishi um okay so uh this is
joint work with rishi santalia he is now
at
ucla this work was done when he was a
graduate student at the university of
michigan and um
[Music]
i'm going to talk about
how to represent
data uh data
um
i'm sorry what
your mic cut out for a second or
something
okay
okay i'm trying to i'm trying to do this
from home with a stable internet
connection so um we'll also see if my
dog makes an appearance
okay so uh
right so i'll just jump right in
um
[Music]
if you are handed a bunch of data and
uh it's noisy or it's been corrupted or
you
uh are given distances say between data
points and
all those values are wrong in some way
the picture that you're going to get of
your data
can also be quite distorted you know and
it might
give you a completely different view of
the world so to speak
depending on
how correct or incorrect you've
represented your data or the distances
amongst your data points and so this
talk is about
partly how to repair
this
whoops
this information um and also how to get
better representations of um distances
and metrics uh in your data
okay so the first example that i'm going
to show you is um
an example to get you thinking that ah
yes this actually could cause all kinds
of problems so
you know suppose i take the
swiss roll
data set you know it's ostensibly it's a
manifold right it's all
rolled inside one another and let's say
i've got 2 000 data points and
i use those data points to
compute distances amongst all of them
and uh i get a pairwise distance matrix
and um suppose that i add some noise to
the pairwise distances not to the data
themselves but to the distances
and you know suppose i add noise some
amount of noise to just only five
percent of the distances so five percent
of the entries in my distance matrix is
going to be corrupted and then suppose i
use that corrupted
distance matrix to construct
uh
let's say a 30 nearest neighbor graph
right so
um
uh you know i'm going to
put edges you know amongst
nearby nodes and the edges are going to
uh have you know have edge length
corresponding to the distance um
supposedly between the nodes and uh i'm
gonna do a little thought experiment
where i take clean
a clean version and then i take this
noisy version now what i end up you know
what i am going to try and embed into
two dimensions
is this nearest neighbor graph one which
is nice and clean and the other one
which has roughly eight percent nine
percent of the edge weights just
completely
uh perturbed so you know the edges and
the vertices are exactly the same it's
just that the edge weights are perturbed
and i used both of these as input to iso
map
well the
figure on the left
here shows you know a nice
curve a nice projection
of um of iso map you know everything is
nice and preserved
you know the geometric structure is nice
and preserved but when i give the
what i think of as ever so slightly
perturbed or corrupted distance graph to
iso map when i do the embedding i get
just utter garbage
um
and so this is an example to show you
that if your input to
something as simple as
as iso map it's actually mds you know
underlying under the hood there's
something as simple as uh you know a
very basic very old algorithm like mds
or even something not quite as old as
isomap
uh
if something
if your input is corrupted it can make a
huge amount of difference in the output
and so it behooves us to
uh
represent our data um or our distances
um accurately
with a metric um perhaps denoised in
some sense
otherwise you know all sorts of
downstream tasks are just garbage
okay so um i got interested in problems
like this um after listening to many
talks
on
uh single cell sequencing data analysis
and sort of bioinformatics more
generally um
a lot of the kinds of data sets that
folks were interested in analyzing in
single cell sequencing were very large
and quite sparse
matrices that were of the form you know
number of cells this might be ten
thousand
um
these days it might be on the order of a
million by
genes let's say ten thousand twenty
thousand genes and many of the entries
in this matrix were zero
now it's not known whether they should
be zero or or whether
um the just the depth of the read wasn't
good enough um so i guess what i should
say is uh
what each entry in this matrix is is the
number of times you know this gene was
expressed in this cell
so uh
it gives you uh
a snapshot of the gene expression
in
a population of cells and what a lot of
the
bioinformatics
questions
or algorithms people were trying to use
what they involved was converting this
matrix into
um
distances between cells so
putting this information in
in cell space to try and you know
cluster cells try and classify them try
and figure out um you know what are
various marker genes
for different types of cells trying to
determine sort of what is the sequence
of um
uh what is a developmental trajectory of
um you know either an uh an organism
like an embryo or you know some sort of
uh organ system developing in an embryo
and you know
who knows how correct or incorrect
these distances in cell space
really were because you know all of
these values
are um
are potentially corrupted
and they're also possibly too low
because you know all of these entries
many of these entries are zero or
they're small and so um
this is really where i began to get the
idea that you know if if these distances
are are not correct how can you possibly
have have you possibly have any sort of
guarantees on your uh on your algorithm
uh you know downstream that you're going
to run it on you know
how do you know that these cells are
clustered together when you know your
idea of who's close to one another is
just garbage
and so i thought you know really we
should come up with some algorithms that
um capture
with much greater fidelity if the
salient features of the data so that
these machine learning algorithms
further downstream would be much better
and so you know there's going to be some
trade-off and how do you exploit the
very specific geometry of you know let's
say cell space in which we represent the
data and
you know how much
uh what kind of features you can get for
your learning algorithms okay i see a
hand raised
hey yeah do you hear me if i just yell
yeah
kind of
uh though the session chairs
graciously giving me the mic um
okay it was seemingly important on your
previous motivation slide that you
talked about making the perturbations
on the distances themselves
rather than the perturbations to the
locations of the points because the
latter would would still preserve a
metric it would just be a slightly messy
metric that's correct but this second
thing you're talking about it looks
naively like it's more like the sec it's
more like perturbing the locations
because if i view if i view the row of
your matrix as specifying a location
and then you say well a bunch of these
entries of the row are corrupted that's
like saying i moved i moved the cell in
the cell's location if the coordinates
of location are genes
right so somehow it feels like
yeah can you clarify this like which of
these noise models it seems like it
makes a big difference which noise model
you think about
um
in some ways yes in some ways no i guess
what i'm going to say is that the single
cell data is so sparse
that any of the robustness
um
uh guarantees for iso map or you know
sort of how much noise you can add to
for example data that you run through
iso map they just don't work
it's just it's just too much noise also
it's not the same kind of noise um these
are you know essentially
uh they're zeros it's like you know
eliminating a bunch of coordinates um
so it is the case that with this amount
of um
of uh
[Music]
missing information
in the
matrix uh the distances
actually do fail to be a metric
i mean they do you know if you if you
you know do something stupid like uh
like a l2 distance um you know the
values that you get out
don't satisfy uh
uh triangle inequality okay
somebody that doesn't that doesn't make
i mean if if you view the rows as
vectors in a vector space
then they have
like then they sort of have to as
vectors in a metric space they have to
right i don't i'm a little can hang on a
second some something
is going wrong with my computer
hang on
okay now i have lost my slides
oh there we go
okay
okay
um
yeah so um
yes i frequently get this question but
hey wait a minute you know uh the
function that i use to compute these
distances it's still a metric
um
in this i'm imagining distance is is
literally like l2 distance between these
rows is that right yeah if i made that
distance
yeah so um you know
typically you know typically people
uh
you know they'll they'll do all kinds of
um
uh crazy hacks
to to um to come up with some number
here that actually makes any sense you
know if you were to just blindly do some
kind of l2 distance um
and you know wherever you have zeros you
just you know you just make it a zero
it's not going to make any sense at all
okay the point is that if you use l2
which would make it a metric it's just
that it's going to be a very crappy
metric like this metric is not useful
for understanding
your data so you have to do something
else to denoise it but now you're not
really going to get a metric
yeah okay thanks
yeah yeah yeah
okay
all right so um
i'm gonna talk about uh a couple of
families of problems that sort of all
fit under this rubric um and um
i call this metric learning
knowing full well that it's uh sort of
an overloaded term that it refers to
some specific problem but i would like
to make this a much more
general
problem and say you know what we're
going to look at three different kinds
of metric learning problems one one of
which is um
in the spirit of the original version so
the first one is
metric nearness which is given a set of
distances
find the closest
metric to these distances in you know in
some lp norm
um you know closest in l1 or you know
whatever l2
um and so
uh
this is a setting where you know your
the input to the algorithm is a set of
distances they um
they may be corrupted
you know they may have been corrupted in
some way they may be completely
inaccurate
uh values etc so the next version of the
problem that we tackled was um
correlation clustering the idea of
partitioning nodes in a graph according
to their similarity you're given
nodes that are similar and those that
are dissimilar and you are supposed to
partition the graph into two clusters um
and then metric learning where you're
given data points
and um you're given information about
those that are similar and those that
are dissimilar and you want to try and
find a metric which is as consistent as
possible with this similarity or
dissimilarity information
about the data
okay so
to be so these are the
three types of problems that we're
interested in tackling
um
i'm going to give some precise
definitions now so we can set up the
statements of these
problems um i have a distance function i
guess this should be from x plus x into
r
it
measures how far
uh points are from one another
i could alternatively represent that in
a matrix capital d of pairwise distances
um sometimes i operate on a on a graph g
which is a weighted graph which is
induced
by the data set where the weights are
the distances um
amongst the data points
and um
you know i'm interested in finding
metrics so i'm interested in the
combinatorial object the metric polytope
on n
points as well as its uh its projection
um onto the coordinates that are given
by the edges of some graph g so the
metric polytope and on endpoints in the
metric polytope um
that's the projection onto the graph g
for these n points
and um it's important to observe
um
the
generalization of the triangle
inequality for a generic graph
is
a cycle
inequality or cycle constraint if you
will you should have no edge
in
in any cycle that is um heavier i.e is
longer than the sum of
the
uh
edges in the in the rest of the cycle so
you know the standard triangle
inequality uh the triangle is the cycle
and you have no edge you know longer
than the sum of the other two edges in
the cycle
and to observe that
the metric polytope induced by the graph
g
is given by an intersection of
half spaces
potentially a lot of them depending on
how many cycles
are in this graph
okay
those are the objects
under our study
and now i'm going to talk about
specific problem formulations of
these various types of
metric learning problems so
this is a slightly different order than
i gave first
sort of easier to understand so
correlation clustering i'm given a graph
g and dis similarity measures on each
edge
um
plus and minus and i want to partition
the nodes into clusters so as to
um if you will sort of minimize the
mislabeling of
of edges
this is a hard problem and so
we'll relax it to
putting
weights
on
edges
and minimizing the
discrepancy of the length i guess i
should say lengths instead of weights i
think of these as weights minimizing the
discrepancy of the
lengths of the edges discrepancy with
the similarity and dissimilarity
information and i want those lengths to
obey a triangle inequality
so no longer are they simply zero or one
the partition but they
they must obey a triangle inequality
um the metric nearness problem is easier
for me to state in terms of the objects
that we
defined
previously so for the metric nearness
problem i'm given
a matrix d
it is an
n by n matrix of distances and i wish to
find the closest metric to those
distances in some
lp norm so i wish to minimize the lp
distance between m and d where m lies in
the metric poly type one end points
okay now i put in red a couple of
different variations of these problems i
put them in red because they are not
convex variations
of um of this problem i could ask
what is the closest
tree metric
to my given data or what is the closest
delta hyperbolic metric
to my data
those are interesting questions but
um
they don't fit this nice
form
i will talk about them at the end
okay um
about the correlation clustering so your
transition variable xc is defined on the
edges so it sounds like you're just
classifying whether the edges are within
the clusters or across different
clusters
yes that's the original version with the
zero one weighting and that's not an
optimization problem i wish to solve
or i guess i should say it's not one i
wish to attempt to solve
so instead i'm going to relax it to
something much more reasonable
and i i want to put distances on the
edges
right right so i guess my question is
that you're saying your goal is to
partition notes into clusters but it
sounds like you only classify the edges
well how about how about how about
putting distances from clusters on the
edges
i think i think the question is just in
the original problem formulation
is is there a requirement like not the
one you're going to solve but in the
original one is there a requirement that
there's that these zero ones are
consistent with some underlying
clustering
yes
okay well i mean i i i i i should be
careful because the information that
you're given or is just you know
positive and negative
uh
uh
on an edge
and you know saying these two vertices
are are positive and these two vertices
are
negative what
you're supposed to output a clustering
well i am supposed to output a labeling
on edges either zero or one you know
zero meaning uh you know the two edges
that this sorry the two vertices that
are on this edge are are um
you know either depending on what your
meaning of zero and one is let's say
they are not in the same cluster
and then the and then the other version
is they are in the same cluster
so i don't know whether or not you want
to call that a clustering because it's
not actually a labeling of vertices it's
a labeling at the edges
okay uh it's a little confusing because
uh somehow
like then then then it seems like you
trivially just you you know you pick
you break it you put you put a label on
the edge to be one if you know w plus is
bigger and an edge to be and you make it
zero if w minus is bigger or something
and i just don't even pay attention to
whether i've consistently done anything
to the vertices
yeah but you're summing all these up and
you want to minimize this quantity
so you want to find the labeling zero or
one that minimizes this sum
okay i think it's not so important for
the
next part since you're not going to
solve this anyway so maybe no
no i don't i don't want to solve that
one yeah
okay
um
yes there are many complaints one could
make about correlation clustering
okay so here's a
general version
of the
original metric learning problem which
is you're given
two sets of pairs of data points the
first set of pairs is those that are
similar and the second set is those that
are dissimilar and you wish to find a
metric that has small distances
you know between
those pairs that are similar and
a lot and large distances between those
that are dissimilar so one very natural
objective function to try and optimize
says you know look
i have some weight lambda i wish to
find the metric m
you know that
puts similar points close together and
puts dissimilar points far apart and i
have you know this weight lambda and one
minus lambda over here now the original
metric near this paper said hey you know
look this problem is too hard to solve
so instead what we'll do is we'll try
and find what is essentially a
re-weighting
of euclidean space
um
uh you know let's just find a diagonal
um quadratic form that goes in between
you know those various
quadratic forms for euclidean space and
you know essentially we're just learning
this vector it's just a re-weighting of
euclidean space
but we we actually want to solve the
much more general problem you know what
what is the point in the metric polytope
that minimizes the subjective function
okay so
hopefully i have
convinced you in setting up these
problems
that um
there's actually a very general problem
formulation underlying
all of these families of problems
and it is of the following form let me
minimize or give me the point that
minimizes
some i'm going to say strictly convex
function f
over
let's say the metric polytope
um
that corresponds to the projection of
the graph g g might actually be the
complete graph in which case the metric
polytope is is exactly the same um
and i might also throw in some
additional constraints so i'm going to
throw in the additional constraints you
know in this form ax is less than or
equal to b
um
and
you know the reason why we allow for
these additional constraints is like for
the correlation clustering problem these
variables might be in between zero and
one not just any
any sort of
value okay so we've got a strictly
convex function that we wish to optimize
over um a convex set
and uh you know subject to some nice any
nice ish inequality constraints okay so
we called this
type of problem formulation a metric
constrained problem now you want to
optimize some function
um
[Music]
over metrics
over the metric polytope
and um you know
how do you do that
um
most i just quickly ask one very very
brief question yes i think it's related
to some of the questions that were asked
before but you're framing the problem
just purely in terms of the edges right
like in some of the original motivations
you talked about there's also like the
x's had
you know they were actually points that
were drawn like plus zero ones or
whatever and a cell type thing but
you're complete you're going to
completely ignore this and only think of
of distances is that
okay all right cool
so there's there's nothing there's no
operational interpretation we should
assign to the nodes except through the
distances
no
the reason is that a lot of existing
methods would try and do things to the
data points
i mean all kinds of imputation methods
would try and fill in the zeros for
example in the
single cell data matrix and um
we didn't think that was maybe
necessarily such a good approach
especially since many many machine
learning algorithms would
convert the data into distances
and run from there so that's why we
took that approach
um okay so
um
you know a lot of existing
uh constrained uh optimization problems
um
sorry a lot of existing methods
for constrained optimization problems
with lots of constraints for example you
know order n cubed uh
constraints for just simple triangle
inequalities um you know possibly
exponentially many uh constraints if
you're looking at you know sort of
ensuring that no cycle is a heavy has a
heavy edge um
uh you know
existing methods for trying to solve
these problems
don't scale particularly well or just
far too many constraints um and you know
a couple of the sort of standard
techniques to
um circumvent these problems uh
themselves would have problems so if you
wanted to just sample
the the constraints sort of you know in
every iteration um it would take a lot
of iterations
to get through
all n cubed um
all n cubed constraints and uh you know
it would uh
it would take a while to visit them
enough times
um you know lagrangian formulations
don't help also with these scaling or
convergence problems so
um
rishi uh came up with um
uh an algorithm called project and
forget
which um
is a
it's a nice take on um
sort of active set methods with a clever
use of an oracle um
and it's an iterative method for solving
these convex problems subject to
metric constraints
um so it it consists of two steps
project and forget um and so the project
step is simply a bregman projection um
and it's done in such a way that it
doesn't have to cycle through
all of these constraints um and then and
then there's a forget step
which says you know look are there any
constraints for which we haven't made
any updates
and if there are uh then you know just
forget them because we've already
satisfied them and we can move on
um so we have
uh
analysis of this algorithm
uh under under
i think the appropriate mild uh
hypotheses uh that this algorithm
converges to the global
optimal solution
and
with
one or two more i think reasonably mild
assumptions on the objective function we
can get an exponential
decay rate asymptotically for the error
what's also kind of nice about the proof
of the
uh
of the convergence is that you can see
that the set of constraints at the end
when the algorithm terminates is exactly
the set of
of active constraints so
i won't go through the proof
of the theorem but i will discuss the
ideas behind the algorithm itself and
then i will discuss
how it performs
in practice on a bunch of different
examples and how it led us to
more
generalizations and um and actually one
of its forerunners okay so i will also
say there's a stochastic variant
um
i won't say too much about that
okay so
what does the algorithm look like
well
you know while you're not done
project oh actually excuse me while
you're not done
get us get a list
of constraints that are violated you get
a list of metric violations this is the
oracle
piece and i will discuss this more in
detail in a second but let's just say
we've got some oracle that returns a
list a pretty good list
of constraints that are violated we
throw that list into our
you know current list of constraints
that we need to do something about we
project
onto um we do a brevin projection onto
those the hyper planes defined by those
constraints and then we look to see is
there anything that we didn't update and
if so forget that constraint and so you
can see you know these pieces
down here this is the bregman projection
this is the forget step um
[Music]
i'm trying to think what comes next
okay so
um
i should say
that this assumes
um that this bregman projection um
uh is easier or worse uh depending on
what the exact form um
of the
gradient of f is and um you know what
this analytic form is um let's i this is
written so as to assume that you have
all that information but you know there
are ways around that if you don't
okay so what's the separation oracle
for this algorithm so
you know the number of constraints
that
you have in order to satisfy a metric
you know especially with these
graph cycle things uh maybe
just
you know incredibly numerous there may
be far too many and so just simply
writing them down even possibly might be
computationally infeasible and so the
only way that you can access them is
through a
separation oracle and um basically you
have a we have a deterministic
separation oracle um that will return a
pretty good list
of violated
constraints and it's pretty good in some
technical sense um you know they can't
they can't be uh too far
maybe uh yeah from the
from uh being violated and then there's
a
sorry there's a stochastic version of
this you know we just replace
deterministic with a randomized
version
okay so what's an example
of um
such an article that has this property
um well it's one called uh
well it's called metric violations but
essentially it is uh essentially it is
to run a shortest path algorithm
on um
on all of the graphs oh sorry on all of
the edges
in the in the graph and you know if the
if the length
of the
edge between node i and j is greater
than the shortest path
um
then
you know you have a violated constraint
and um you know for most
uh
yeah so that's the uh
that's the separation oracle and uh now
i'm gonna let you guys think about how
to prove
how to prove that proposition
okay
all right uh usually when i talk about
this i get i sometimes i get a question
about bregman projection hopefully i
explain that a little bit um
while walking through the pseudocode
okay
so this is a summary
of the results of the theorem i said you
know with mild i think assumptions on
the uh objective function
um and you know how are the hyperplanes
arranged with respect to this
objective function you know then the
algorithm converges the optimal solution
if you know something about the
objective function like it's twice
differentiable and you know at the
optimal solution and you know it's
hessian
is nice then you can get a convergence
rate uh
for this algorithm and also the proof
reveals this nice active set
idea
okay you know theory is great
but how does it work
like does it actually work
so
um
i'm gonna go through a couple of
examples
um
[Music]
uh
a couple of example problems and a
couple of the um you know sort of the
state of the art
at least as it was six months or so ago
a year ago uh for these problems um and
a couple of them we we worked with the
the folks who uh
implemented these state-of-the-art
solvers um and i want to emphasize here
that um
we did not
do
any sort of special
implementations for each version of the
problem it's actually quite a
generic implementation
um
uh
so you know
the goal was to show that this is quite
a powerful technique not you know that
we could solve we could tweak it to do
this and that and that
okay so the first problem
variation that we looked at was weighted
correlation clustering and here these
are for dense graphs
as you all
may know
solving shortness path problems makes a
big difference whether the graph is
sparse or dense
so uh
david gleick and his student nate
student at the time nate belt
um
had uh
uh nice implementations um for solving
this dense graph you know weighted
correlation clustering and they showed
that you know just sort of out of the
box standard solvers like the roby you
know can only tackle
uh about
uh
graphs with about 4 000 nodes
and this was a few years ago so i don't
know how
reasonable
size machine this is
right now um
so belt and his thesis developed a
method for
solving
graphs with you know roughly 11 000
nodes by transforming to a slightly
different
uh a slightly different lp slightly
different
optimization problem um and this is the
version of the problem that we
solved um here you know i've got the
complete graph
uh this is the metric polytope on the
complete graph
and
this
gamma here i believe controls
the approximation
the
approximation factor to the optimal um
i'll have to go check on the next slide
to see if that really is the case but uh
we really wanted to compare apples to
apples
and solve the same problem that belt did
so we took uh four graphs from the
stanford network repository and compared
the running time quality of the
solutions that we got and
how much memory uh we used
for the same graphs that veldt did so
when they did the implementation
um glyc and velt added someone else
ruggles so
it's rubbles at all and we took the same
four graphs that that they did these are
dense
weighted graphs for correlation
clustering here we get up to 11 000.
so
you know our running time is
considerably faster our optimality ratio
again this is this you know how
it's controlled by gamma
uh is is better i.e we're getting uh
a more optimal solution
a less bad
approximation
to the optimal solution um than their
implementation the only kind of funny
thing that's going on here is that the
average memory usage per iteration
their algorithm does does better
and
um you know so we went to go investigate
this this seems kind of strange for an
algorithm that is supposedly some sort
of active set method that is rejecting
ejecting
constraints um after they've been
satisfied uh so it turns out indeed that
is what's happening and just computing
an average
an average memory usage per iteration
doesn't really show what happens over
over some number of iterations so
um you know after about 10 iterations
uh project and forget has sort of
settled on the number of constraints
um
uh that are you sort of needed to to get
to the
optimal solution it starts out with a
whole bunch of them
and uh you know pretty soon
forgets all of them
um and so you know on average though
this is kind of high it makes for kind
of high memory usage but you know you do
get this kind of performance
you can also see that the
maximum violation of the metric
constraints is decreasing
as as we go which is
as we expected from theoretical analysis
okay dense graphs are one thing sparse
graphs are
much different
uh so we took a bunch of sparse graphs
which were huge
um
you know one of these sparse graphs has
130 000 nodes
which one would think would make for
roughly 10 to the 15th
metric constraints
and in 120 some odd hours we were able
to
solve the weighted correlation
clustering with pretty decent
optimality ratio and in fact actually
only let's say roughly 600 000 active
constraints and 193
iterations
so
um way beyond the realm
of uh
what uh like and veldt and ruggles could
do
um david gleick actually was so excited
about this that he interviewed us in the
middle of
um serious lockdown pandemic and he
recorded it and made this really nice
video and uh it was actually really cool
like he really wanted to know how did we
do this
it was kind of neat
um okay so the next problem
that i'm going to talk about uh is a
metric nearness
problem and um the reason why i included
this one um is not not because the
problem
in and of itself is so interesting or so
important um
but sort of where you can go from here
is really interesting and it's actually
the this is the
the problem that got me thinking
about this area
um sort of originally as well as sitting
through a bunch of bioinformatics talks
um
so
just to remind you you're given a matrix
d of distances and you want to find the
closest metric closest in some lp norm
to the input matrix
and uh this was originally
stated and sort of solved in a paper by
raquel and tropp
and dylan
um in about 2007
um i think it was originally
part
of work that joel trapp did as a
graduate student
um
and
um
they
uh came up with uh
a couple of different methods for
solving this problem with where p equals
two i believe and also i think
p equals one
um the important part is that they did
two kinds of experiments for weighted
complete graphs they took a random
binary distance matrices and random
gaussian
distance matrices and then tried to find
the closest metric to those random
matrices
um and so you know just
for the sake of comparison
uh
we looked at
you know the average running time of our
algorithm versus raquel's i believe that
this is rishi's implementation of
raquel's algorithm because i don't think
there is one
sort of publicly available from
that long ago
but rishi you'll have to correct me if
i'm wrong
okay
all right you know basically this is
like saying you know what
we're slightly fat we're we're faster
um
um
for these types for type 1 and type 2
graphs
okay so i have just a very few minutes
um and i want wanna i wanna talk about
um
a couple of other directions that um a
we went in and b you know sort of uh
uh inspired this original
work so the first one
um
[Music]
um
suppose you want to find the first one
is a sort of a sparse metric repair
version of the metric nearness problem
and that is replace this p norm with the
l zero pseudo norm
so give me the fewest
number of changes that you have to make
to this matrix of distances in order to
find
the
the closest in you know to find the
closest metric um so that was actually
the problem that started all of this
and once
we
realized
um
that people were interested in
um
well actually people would ask us for
this metric nearness problem and for
sparse metric repair they would ask us
well what metric do you repair to
could you repair to a certain kind of
metric and so that actually got us
thinking oh
maybe we want to do some sort of
embedding or
representation
or you know find the closest
specific kind of metric like a tree
metric or embed the points in
some hyperbolic space so find the you
know
set of distances in hyperbolic space
that best represents the data
and um also at the same time folks in
single cell sequencing we're looking at
hyperbolic representations of um single
cell data and of course people have done
this for linguistics and um
social network analysis and so we came
up with an algorithm called tree rep
which tries to find the um best tree
representation
of your set of distances and so
um
i'll just i'll end here with this
picture
um so tree wrap goes from distances to
tree structure
um which you can then embed in let's say
the plunker a disk
um
like two-dimensional hyperbolic space
um and um
no hopefully it is useful for uh
all sorts of tree-like
data
so we're currently investigating its
applications okay
it is at this point that i'm going to
stop and see if there are any more
questions
i'm just checking this is the end of the
talk
yes okay perfect let's thank anna yes
thank you
it was the way you placed it i wasn't
quite sure any questions
maybe i'll ask one quick one
but given that you don't actually assign
any operational meaning to the nodes
themselves
um if a new data point arrived in your
data set
and you have the metric that you've
learned and it's not necessarily you
know an l2 metric or a
it's not necessarily whatever no this
metric there's no like explicit way to
parameterize distances now that you
don't know what that point actually
represents
yeah
is there a way to think about this
problem that's independent of just the
data that you were given and assigning
distances between those data sets
um
i don't know that's a good question like
if i got a new point like if i added a
row and a column to my matrix is there
some way that i could you know like jump
up
a dimension
so to speak in my metric polytope and
find
you know and sort of update my
optimal point um i don't know
i don't know but that's a good question
if there aren't any further questions
maybe we should thank anna again
okay thank you
all right so the next session will be a
2.
awesome have a good lunch